je suis devenu presque à mon corps
défendant
c'est très agréable parce que je
m'attendais pas à ça moi j'étais
producteur j'étais à l'arrière scène et
je mets mon métier parce que tu peux
produire beaucoup de choses mais tout à
coup j'ai été dans la lumière
et c'est vrai banquet des avantages vous
les connaissez aussi bien que moi mais
il sait pas allégations cette fois donc
contre gilbert rozon du groupe juste
pour rire on départ pour l'independent à
blanc dans les faits le préfet central
et mais choqué maman m'a donné mon
premier
la première pensée était à fait comme là
tout le monde en parle tout le québec en
parle
à commencer par montréal et son maire
denis coderre lendemain fait chacun mais
là on parle de neuf personnes mais il ya
beaucoup de gens qui peuvent être
surprises ce matin également assez comme
le code monsieur salvail alors
évidemment je défends pas l'indéfendable
su respecter le processus mais le bie
missionné par lui-même en 2014 les
canadiens ont déclaré avoir subi plus de
six cent trente cinq mille agression
sexuelle dans un pays qui comptait alors
35 millions d'habitants et la grande
majorité des victimes dans 87% des cas
ce sont des femmes sa générosité dont
soin de son physique et sa créativité
par l'animateur éric salvail les
victimes alléguées seraient pour leur
part des hommes soit juste un col van
steen stack au rx il
après sophie prégent ans et président de
l'union des artistes sorte de grand
syndicat général pour tout le milieu
artistique québécois
je pense que plus on le dit moins les
gens vont faire parce qu'elles vont
sentir la sueur chaud depuis que sa
fille vont ils vont savoir qu'il va y
avoir des conséquences de ce qui est bon
c'est présentement les conséquences
elles sont et non je compris vous me
parler d'éco ya quelques années mais
cgem est venu gros comme ceole higuain
sting ses gages ce qui se passe ici
c'est grave qui vont peut-être en avoir
dont j'avais aussi des halles les
allégations d'inconduite sexuelle contre
lyn matters et producteur et salva y met
en lumière l'importance de parler des
agressions chez les hommes bien sûr mais
donc des gars font des enfants des ados
des jeunes adultes
bien sûr que c'est beaucoup aimé on en
parle très peu très peu
michel dorais et sociologue de la
sexualité est professeur au département
de service social de l'université laval
dans la ville de québec et que l'on peut
être la moitié de votre votre grandeur
mais leur seule main et tout ce qui est
de type bien la sexuelle d'un rapport de
pouvoir fois parce que vous êtes un
homme bâtisse on peut dire que vous êtes
à l'abri de parce qu'on prépare temps
des hommes enfin quand on en parle on en
parle mais regardez la sphère de daewoo
dont on parle depuis une bonne semaine
sur un bond et des femmes des femmes et
je lis beaucoup les gens regardent les
bd américaine et puis on oublie cui aidé
à demande finalement aussi il ya des
hommes derrière les voitures
oui mais ça arrive aux hommes jeu mais
ne recherchent actuellement sur les
agressions sexuelles chez des personnes
lgbt c'est pareil on va dire oui mais il
est gay un autre de ces deux scandales
en moins de 24 heures
tout cela deux semaines après le
scandale à hollywood de harvey weinstein
tout cela alimente un débat sur la
prévalence des agressions sexuelles dans
les milieux artistiques en amérique mais
contrairement aux états unis canada
il n'y a pas de délai pour porter
plainte et déposer des accusations
criminelles pour agression sexuelle
l'avocat criminaliste m walid hijazi il
n'y a pas de limite pour qu'on appelle
une prescription en droit d aller vers l
intérieur duquel on doit agir si on
dépasse le délai on est hors délais en
vue que ses traits à l'art amateur de
prescription n'est pas de prescription à
droite fine elle l'a souvent des crimes
sont révélés 20 25 30 ans plus tard et
la police n'a pas de délai dans le temps
qu'elle a besoin pour inquiéter
sauf que plus le temps avance plus à la
qualité de la preuve se perd la mémoire
avec une tactique fictive oublié déjà
qu'ils ne se souviennent de ce qui s'est
passé ou il ya déjà qui paraissent à
l'ordre
la qualité de la preuve et est moins
bonne il y aurait par ailleurs une
question territorialité habituellement
on enquête et on poursuit au canada des
crimes qui ont été commis en territoire
qu'elle atteint lorsque les crimes et à
l'étranger à des considérations extra
territorial complique énormément la
taille généralement on poursuit pas pour
des cliniques ont été commis à yar un
reportage de radio canada international